PORTER MOSER HEAD COACH
LOYOLA CHICAGO. HEY COACH.
HOW YOU DOING? I'M GREAT GUYS.
HOW ARE YOU? WE ARE DOING SO
WELL, SO GLAD TO ACTUALLY
HAVE AN NCAA TOURNAMENT TO BE
TALKING ABOUT. I KNOW THE
ONLY PEOPLE HAPPIER THAN US
FOR THE GUYS THAT ARE PLAYING
IN IT AND COACHING IN IT LIKE
YOU ARE CONGRATULATIONS. BY
THE WAY, YOU GUYS ARE JUST
THE THIRD TEAM TO BE THE
NUMBER ONE SEED IN THE SECOND
ROUND BY DOUBLE DIGITS LED
WIRE TO WIRE OVER NUMBER ONE
DOUBLE DIGITS LED WIRE TO
ILLINOIS.
WHAT IS THIS RIDE BEEN LIKE
FOR YOU? I KNOW YOU MADE THE
FINAL FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO. SO I DON'T WANT TO SAY
YOU'RE USED TO IT. BUT THIS
IS NOT NEW AT LEAST FOR A
COUPLE OF THE THE OLDER GUYS
IN YOUR TEAM. YOU KNOW, WE
GOT WE GOT TWO GUYS THAT WERE
ON THAT TEAM LUCAS WILLIAMSON
AT CAMERA CREW WITH BUT
EVERYBODY ELSE IS NEW. SO
WHAT'S REALLY GREAT ABOUT
THIS IS JUST BEEN ABLE TO
SUSTAIN IT THE PROGRAM AND
JUST IT'S A BIG REASON WHY I
STAYED IS JUST, YOU KNOW
FEELING LIKE YOU CAN JUST
KEEP BUILDING SOMETHING
SPECIAL AND IT'S ALL
THE THINGS WE HAD TO GO
THROUGH THIS YEAR THE TWISTS
AND TURNS THE PIVOTS CAN GET
TO THIS POINT AND YOU KNOW TO
GET IN HERE AND THEN YOU KNOW
TO GET IN HERE AND THEN YOU
KNOW IN OUR STATE OF ILLINOIS
TWO RANKED TEAMS GOING AT
EACH OTHER TO GO TO THE SWEET
16 IN THE STORYLINE COULDN'T
HAVE BEEN BETTER FOR THE
LITTLE THE RAMBLERS GOING
INTO THIS THING. IT WAS AN
UNBELIEVABLE STORY LINE AND
OH BY THE WAY, YOU GUYS GET
TO PLAY WITH A BIG OLD CHIP
ON YOUR SHOULDER BECAUSE THE
COMMITTEE I THINK SCREWED THE
POOCH GIVING YOU GUYS AN
EIGHT SEED WHEN YOU'VE BEEN
RANKED IN THE TOP 25 FOR
OVER A MONTH.
YOUR TOP TEN IN THE NET AND
CAN PALM AND ALL THESE OTHER
METRICS. WHAT DID YOU SAY TO
YOUR GUYS WHEN YOU GOT THAT
HC? YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M ALWAYS
TALKING ABOUT CONTROL WHAT
YOU CAN CONTROL SO HE YOU
KNOW, I PART OF THAT WE ALL
KIND OF KNEW WE'RE LIKE, YOU
KNOW, WHAT? ALL RIGHT, LET'S
ROLL WITH IT. LET'S JUST GO
AND BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
CRAZY THING ABOUT IT IS THEY
CAME UP WITH THE NET AND WHAT
IS THE NET STAND FOR? IT'S
NCAA EVALUATION TOOL. THAT'S
WHAT THEY SAID. THEY WERE
GOING TO USE AND WE WERE NINE.
SO THE
ONE THROUGH FOUR GOT ALL THE
ONE SEEDS FIVE THROUGH EIGHT
GOT ALL THE TWO SEEDS AND THE
NINTH GOT THE AC. SO IT JUST
IS WHAT IT IS. I KNOW IT'S A
HARD JOB. I KNOW THEY GOT
THINGS. SO WE REALLY DIDN'T
MAKE THAT BIG OF A CHIP ON
OUR SHOULDER. I THINK WE JUST
SAID, ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
LET'S GO. IT'S ALL ABOUT P***
INTO GEORGIA TECH AND WE BEAT
THEM AND IT WAS ALL ABOUT
ILLINOIS. AND THAT'S KINDA
WHAT WE DID LAST TIME. WE
DIDN'T WORRY ABOUT A LOT OF
THE OUTSIDE STUFF. IT WAS
JUST WHAT WAS IN FRONT OF US
AND OUR GUYS OUR GUYS JUST A
REALLY CLOSE REALLY TOGETHER
AND JUST HAVE THIS CONFIDENCE.
THAT THEY BELIEVE THEY CAN
WIN THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP
AND LAST TIME WE WERE SEVEN
MINUTES AWAY AND WE KNOW WE
GOT SOME OBSTACLES IN FRONT
DAN HALEY FEELING HIM ON THE
RICH EYES AND SHOW WITH PUT
HER MOSER THE HEAD COACH
COACH AT LOYOLA CHICAGO. I
COACH I HAVE TO ASK YOU
BECAUSE I WAS DOING A LITTLE
DEEP DIVE AND WATCHING SOME
YOUTUBE VIDEOS OF SOME
INTERVIEWS AND PODCAST THAT
YOU'VE DONE AND THERE WAS I
CAN'T REMEMBER WHO IT WAS BUT
HE TALKED ABOUT WHAT GREAT
FRIENDS YOU GUYS WERE AT THE
TOP OF THE PODCAST AND THEN
MISPRONOUNCED YOUR LAST NAME
AND YOU CALL THEM RIGHT FROM
THE JUMP AND I LOVE THAT IS
SOMEBODY WHO GETS MY NAME
MISPRONOUNCED ALL THE TIME. I
REALLY APPRECIATED THAT I
THINK IT WAS TWO MILES. I WAS
YEAH.
YEAH, AND HE WAS A GREAT
FRIEND OF MINE AND I WAS JUST
JOKING WITH HIM WHEN HE SAID
THAT AND HE JUST HE GOT YOU
SAID BOSSIER ON THAT TOO. HOW
WOULD THESE IS SO FUNNY HOW
HE IS IT 50/50 THE AMOUNT OF
THOSE TWO MOSER, YOU KNOW
WHAT EXACTLY IT IS. IT'S
ACTUALLY MORE SAY MOSER LIKE
IT'S SH AND I REALLY COULD
CARE LESS. I'M NOT ONE OF
THOSE GUYS. I REALLY DON'T
CARE BUT I JUST HAD TO BUST
HIS CHOPS. WELL ON IT. I LOVE
IT. I LOVE IT WHY I THOUGHT
THAT WAS PRETTY FUNNY. AS I
SAID, YOU KNOW, MY LAST NAME
IS HOLLY AND I CAN'T TELL YOU
HOW OFTEN PEOPLE JUST DON'T
WANT TO SAY HELL SO THEY'LL
SAY HAYLEY YOUR HALLIE. I
MIGHT IT'S HELI. IT'S JUST A
NORWEGIAN NAMED COACH.
NOTHING I CAN DO ABOUT IT.
HEY, SO I LOVE THE EMPHASIS
ON DEFENSE. YOU GUYS ARE THE
BEST
OFFENSIVE TEAM IN THE COUNTRY
AND I'M WONDERING IF IT'S SO
HARD SO MANY COACHES PREACH
DEFENSE. BUT BUT YOU MANIFEST
THAT YOU MAKE IT HAPPY YOUR
PLAYERS MAKE IT HAPPEN. BUT
YOU YOU GUIDE THEM ALONG THAT
PROCESS. DOES THIS GO ALL THE
WAY BACK TO WHEN YOU ATTENDED
A BOBBY KNIGHT CAMP WHEN YOU
WERE A KID THIS LOVE OF
DEFENSE? NO, I WISH I COULD
SAY THAT BUT NO, I DON'T EVEN
HAVE MY MEMORY THAT LONG,
TELL YOU WHAT, YOU KNOW, I
WORKED FOR RICK MAJERUS AND
YOU KNOW, HE WAS SO GOOD
DEFENSIVELY, BUT I THINK IT'S
HOW WE
FRAME IT, YOU KNOW WITH OUR
GUYS IN THE RECRUITING
PROCESS, YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES
YOU SAY, OH WE'RE GOING TO
PLAY DEFENSE. THEY THINK OH
WE'RE GOING TO SLOW IT DOWN.
WE GOT TO PLAY WE KIND OF
FRAME IT LIKE OUR DEFENSE
CREATES OFFENSE, YOU KNOW, WE
GET STOPS. WE CAN RUN. WE WE
GET STEALS WE CAN RUN AND WE
TALKED ABOUT IT. WE FRAME IT
WITH HOW LIKE IN THE PROS
EVERYONE'S TALKING ABOUT
TWO-WAY PLAYERS, YOU KNOW,
KOBE MICHAEL QUI KLAY
THOMPSON, YOU KNOW TWO-WAY
PLAYERS AND WE FRAME IT THAT
WAY. HEY, YOU'RE GOING TO
LEARN WE'RE GOING TO PLAY
CREATE OFFENSE WE
WE ARE GOING AROUND BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN UP IN THE TOP, YOU
KNOW, 40 IN AN OFFENSIVE
EFFICIENCY AS WELL. AND SO I
THINK IT'S HOW YOU FRAME IT
THE GUYS BELIEVE IN IT. THEY
DON'T THINK WE'RE JUST GOING
TO WALK IT UP. THEY THINK
WE'RE GOING TO GUARD OUR
TAILS OFF GET STOPS AND RUN.
SO THEY REALLY BELIEVE IT'S A
WAY WE CAN WIN HAVEN'T CAUGHT
WIGAN WILLIAMSON THERE AS
YOUR AS YOUR SENIOR LEADERS
WHO HAD BEEN THERE BEFORE,
MUCH DO YOU LEAN ON THESE TWO
GUYS, YOU KNOW, IT'S HUGE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, SO WE WON
THE MISSOURI VALLEY
WEEK
THE NATS WERE CELEBRATING YOU
CAN SEE ALL THE GUYS BECAUSE
WE'RE WE GOT A LOT OF NEW
GUYS AND THEY WERE JUST SO
EXCITED AND WE HAD A
CELEBRATION SHUT UP. WE WERE
IN THE LOCKER ROOM AND THOSE
TWO WERE LIKE YOU GUYS THIS
IS AWESOME, BUT IT GETS A LOT
BETTER AND WHEN YOU GOT A
WHEN YOU GUYS GOT VOICES THAT
COME FROM YOUR PEERS YOUR
YOUR FRIENDS, IT JUST CARRIES
MORE WEIGHT BECAUSE THE COACH
CAN ALWAYS SAY THAT HEY I'VE
BEEN THERE BEFORE, YOU KNOW,
WE GOT TO DO THIS, BUT WHEN
THOSE GUYS SAID IT, HEY, IT
GETS A LOT BETTER FROM HERE.
WE GOT A LOCK IN, YOU KNOW,
WE CAN ADVANCE AND BELIEVE
YOU CAN ADVANCE IN THIS THING
AND JUST HUGE JUST HAVING
THOSE
YOU GUYS BEEN ON THAT STAGE
AT THE FINAL FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO. IT'S ALSO A HUGE
TO HAVE 101 YEAR OLD SISTER
JEAN. SHE BECAME A PHENOMENON
NATIONALLY JUST BELOVED BY
EVERYBODY WHEN YOU GUYS MADE
THE FINAL FOUR RUN A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO THE PREGAME
SPEECH BEFORE THE ILLINOIS
GAME. DO YOU GIVE HER A
SCOUTING REPORT OR IS SHE
DOING THIS ON HER OWN? I MEAN,
SHE JUST LOOKED AT THE STATS
AND SHE YOU KNOW, SHE'S SHE
SAID, YOU KNOW, SHE WAS IT'S
NUMBER 35, YOU KNOW, SHE'S
UNBELIEVABLY SHARP NOW, BUT
IT'S FUNNY HOW IT KIND OF
MORPHED INTO A SCATTERING FOR
IT. IT'S NOT EASY, BUT
SHE'S SO MUCH A PART OF WHO
WE ARE FABRIC. SHE DOES GIVE
THE GUY'S A BLESSING BEFORE
THEY GO AND YOU KNOW, THIS
THIS TIME THROUGH THE PHONE,
BUT YOU KNOW, 401 YEARS OLD.
SHE STILL EMAILS US EACH ONE
OF US AFTER THE GAME EVERY
GAME AND SHE'S JUST REALLY
SHARP AND SHE YOU KNOW, SHE'S
SHE'S WOVEN IN THE FABRIC OF
WHO WE ARE
HOLD ON A SECOND. SHE WHEN
YOU SAY EACH ONE OF US AS IN
JUST ABOUT THE COACHING STAFF
THE PLAYERS. EVERYBODY KNOW I
GET A PERSONAL EMAIL THEN SHE
SENDS EACH PLAYER PERSONAL
EMAIL AFTER EVERY GAME.
THAT'S INCREDIBLE. YEAH EVERY
GAME MY IN-LAWS WHO ARE FAR
FROM A HUNDRED AND ONE DO NOT
SEND EMAILS. THAT'S THAT'S
IMPRESSED. WELL MIGHT I WANT
TO CORRECT MYSELF. MY
FATHER-IN-LAW DOES MY
MOTHER-IN-LAW DOESN'T SO THEY
COULD BE WATCHING RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T WANT TO GET IN
TROUBLE. THAT'S ALL YOU KNOW
ABOUT THAT. WHAT IS
WAS IT WAS THERE A QUESTION
MARK ABOUT HER
SISTER GREAT ATTEND A GAME
ARCH MADNESS, WHICH IS THE
MISSOURI VALLEY TOURNAMENT IN
ST.LOUIS. THEY DIDN'T LET HER
GO AND THEN I TALKED TO HER
AFTER WE GOT BACK AND SHE WAS
PISSED. SHE WAS LIKE
, I GOT 30 STRAIGHT TEST I'M
GOING AND RIGHT THEN I KNEW
THAT LIKE SHE'S GETTING HER
AND SURE ENOUGH SHE'S HERE
AND EVERYBODY'S FIRED UP THAT
SHE'S UP IN THE BALCONY
SISTER. JEAN IS A BEAST. I
LOVE IT. OH GOSH, I
TEAM TO WATCH IT'S FUN TO
WATCH YOU GUYS PLAY SHE'S A
GREAT STORY. I LOVE YOUR TIES
TO RICK MAJERUS. HE WAS ONE
OF MY FAVORITE COACHES JUST
FROM AFAR, YOU KNOW WHEN HE
WAS AT UTAH WAY BACK IN THE
DAY. I LOVE THE WAY THAT HIS
HIS TEAM PLAYED AND I SAW
THAT YOU STARTED JOURNALING
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT I'VE
BEEN TELLING MYSELF FOR THE
LAST DECADE THAT I'M GOING TO
DO AND I HAVE YET TO DO IT,
BUT YOU STARTED DOING THAT
BECAUSE OF MAJORIS. IS THAT
RIGHT? YEAH. THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU JUST YOU KNOW ONE IT WAS
JUST EVERY DAY. I WAS JUST
LEARNING STUFF. SO I HAD LIKE
A BASKETBALL.
BALL JOURNAL GOING AND THEN I
HAD ANOTHER SIDE ONE OF JUST
CRAZY HILARIOUS STORIES AND
I'M LIKE, I GOT TO START
WRITING THIS DOWN. I MEAN,
THERE'S JUST SO MUCH THAT WAS
YOU KNOW, AND THEN WE GET
TOGETHER GUYS THAT WORK THAT
IT PLAYED FOR HIM AND THEN
COAST WITH THEM. WE'LL SEE
EACH OTHER AND WE'LL JUST
START TELLING STORIES AND
JUST LAUGH AND SO I STARTED
WRITING THEM DOWN AND I GOT
ABOUT A HUNDRED PAGES JUST
HILARIOUS STORIES. I'LL SIT
UP ON MY FIRE PIT. SOMETIMES
IT JUST START LAUGHING
REHASHING SOME OF THE STORIES.
HE MEANT SO MUCH TO ME, BUT
HE WAS ALSO A GREAT FRIEND
HILARIOUS GUY SO MUCH FUN,
BUT HE WAS A GENIUS TOO.
THEY'RE IN THE FOUR YEARS. I
SPENT AS ASSOCIATE HEAD COACH
AS ST. LOUIS. WE JUST SITTING
IN A BOARDROOM AND LIKE
WATCHING HIS MIND TWIST AND
TURN AND GAME PLAYING AND IT
WAS IT WAS LIKE I WAS GETTING
A PHD FROM THE GUY, YOU KNOW,
I JUST MEANT A LOT TO ME AND
HE'S GONE WAY TOO EARLY. DID
YOU YOU'VE WRITTEN A BOOK
USING SOME OF THOSE STORIES?
IS THAT RIGHT OR NO? NO. NO,
THAT WAS A DIFFERENT. LIKE I
ALWAYS THOUGHT IF I WAS GOING
TO WRITE A BOOK IT WAS GOING
TO BE YOU KNOW, REMEMBER HOW
STEVE ALFORD HAD A BOOK AND
HE PUT IT OUT. IT WAS CALLED
PLAYING FOR NIGHT, AND I'VE
WERE READING IT COVER TO
COVER LIKE AND I JUST THOUGHT
IT WAS RIVETING. JUST WHAT
WAS LIKE TO PLAY FOR NIGHT
AND I GOT I GET ASKED THE
QUESTION ALL THE TIME,
ESPECIALLY MY FIRST, YOU KNOW,
I WAS WORKING FOR ME TO BE
LIKE HEY, WHAT'S IT LIKE
WORKING FOR IMAGE AIRES?
EVERYONE ALWAYS ASKS ME A
QUESTION. SO I WAS GOING TO
WRITE I WAS MY MIND WAS
ALWAYS GOING TO WRITE A BOOK
CALLED WORKING FOR MY CHERISH
AND THEN I GOT AFTER THE
FINAL FOUR. I GOT APPROACHED
BY THE LOYOLA JESUIT, PRESS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. I THINK
THEY WANT A DIFFERENT PATH
FOR THIS BOOK. IT WAS IT WAS
MORE OF MY PATH MY JOURNEY OF
MY JOURNEY OF HOW I GOT TO
LOYOLA AND GET TO THE FINAL
FOUR AND SO ENDED UP DOING
THAT BUT SOMEDAY I MIGHT DO
IT SOMEDAY I MIGHT DO IS
SOMETHING AND IT WOULD BE
WON'T BE DISPARAGING AT ALL.
IT'LL BE MORE HONORING HIM
BUT TELLING FUNNY STORIES OF
HOW YOU KNOW, BECAUSE THERE
WAS NO ONE LIKE A THERE WAS
NO ONE LIKE HIM IN OUR
PROFESSION. YEAH. HE ONE OF
THE ALL-TIME GREATS AND
DEFINITELY MISSED BY ALL
COLLEGE BASKETBALL FANS
AROUND THE COUNTRY. I DO NEED
TO ASK YOU ABOUT WHAT YOU
HAVE COMING UP THE MIDWEST.
REGION IS JUST COMPLETELY
TURNED UPSIDE DOWN YOU GUYS
DESPITE BEING THE EIGHTH SEED
COMING IN YOUR THE SECOND
HIGHEST SEED REMAINING. AND
AND NOW YOU HAVE OREGON STATE
COMING UP. WHAT'S THE WHAT'S
THE SCOUTING REPORT? YOU HAVE
ONE YET ON THE BEAVERS. YEAH.
I MEAN, THEY'RE VERY GOOD.
THEY'RE VERY HOT. I MEAN
THINK ABOUT THIS WE DREW THE
ACC TOURNAMENT CHAMPS. THEY
WERE HOT COMING IN THEN WE
DREW THE BIG TEN CHAMPS.
THEY WERE HOT COMING IN NOW.
WE'RE DRAWING THE PAC-12
TOURNAMENT CHAMPS THREE
STRAIGHT TOURNAMENT CHAMPS OF
POWER.
FIVE CONFERENCES SO, YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE VERY WELL COACH
COACH CAN'T GO DOES AN
AWESOME JOB. THEY'RE HOT
THEY'RE SHOOTING AT THEY GOT
A BIG MAN. THEY CAN A GREAT
POINT GUARD. YOU KNOW,
THEY'RE GONNA BE HARD TO
GUARD AND I THINK THAT'S A
BIG PART OF IT. AND THEN YOU
LOOK AT THE DEFENSE ON THE
OTHER TWO GAMES WITH SYRACUSE
IN HOUSTON. YOU'VE GOT TO
TO CONTRASTING STYLES. YOU
GOOD DEFENSE IN THE COUNTRY
AND THEN YOU GOT SYRACUSE WHO
JUST HAS THAT LONG LONG ZONE
THAT YOU JUST GOT TO FIGURE
OUT AND THEY'RE SHOOTING IT.
WELL, SO SOME VERY HOT
TEAMS COMING IN HERE IN
THESE LAST FOUR TEAMS.
BEFORE WE LET YOU GO DAN
HALEY FILLING IN FOR RICH
EISEN WITH PORTER MOSER
LITTLE CHICAGO HEAD COACH
COACH. WHAT ARE YOU? WHAT ARE
YOU WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
KEEP BUSY WHEN YOU GUYS
AREN'T PRACTICING AND PLAYING
DID YOU ARE YOU GUYS DO YOU
HAVE EVERYTHING SCHEDULED OUT
EVERY HOUR? WE'RE DOING THIS.
WE'RE
WATCHING GAMES TOGETHER AS A
TEAM OR DO GUYS GET FREE TIME.
I KNOW THERE'S REALLY
NOWHERE TO GO TO KIND OF DO
THEIR OWN THING. SO THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION DAN HALLY.
THERE WE GO. I LOVE THE
ANNUNCIATION. I LISTEN NO,
BUT I TELL YOU IF THAT'S A
WHEN WE GOT HERE. WE HAD TO
GO TO QUARANTINE. SO WE GOT
HERE SUNDAY NIGHT. WE
ACTUALLY WATCH SELECTION SHOW
IN THE INDY 500 SPEEDWAY,
WHICH IS REALLY COOL. THEY
LET US TAKE OUR BUSES AROUND
BECAUSE ONCE YOU CHECK IN THE
HOTEL YOU HAD TO TEST AND GET
PUT IN QUARANTINE AND I'M
LIKE I'M WATCHING
ELECTION SHOW WITH MY GUYS
AND I'M NOT DOING A SEPARATE
OUR ROOMS. SO WE CHECKED IN
SUNDAY NIGHT. TESTED HAD TO
QUARANTINE WOKE UP HAD TO
TEST AGAIN QUARANTINE AGAIN.
SO THEN ONCE IT WAS ALMOST
MONDAY NIGHT WHEN YOU GOT OUT
SO REALLY TUESDAY, WEDNESDAY,
THURSDAY YOUR YOUR PRACTICE
IN PREPARING AND YOU DON'T
GET TO GO OUT OUTSIDE MUCH,
BUT THIS IS THE WEEK THAT WE
GOT TO BE REALLY AWARE BECAUSE
ANOTHER WEEK HERE YOU WE
HAVEN'T HAD MUCH TIME TO GO
OUTSIDE. THEY REALLY GOT YOU
IN A BUBBLE. THEY'VE BEEN
SEASONED REALLY WELL
ORGANIZED WITH THE TESTING
THERE'S SOME DOWN TIME AND
THIS IT'S GOING TO BE THIS
WEEK. SO WE'VE BEEN COMING UP
WITH SOME THINGS TO GET THESE
GUYS MENTALLY LOOSE AND FREE
AND JUST SO MUCH WHERE THEY
GET OUT AND DO SOMETHING. SO
THIS WEEK IS THE BIG WEEK FOR
THIS. YEAH, THAT'S GOING TO
BE THAT'S GOING TO BE MAYBE
YOUR MOST CHALLENGING JOB IS
TO FIND STUFF FOR FOR THE
KIDS TO DO. WE TALKED TO PAUL
MILLS ORAL ROBERTS HEAD COACH.
THEY'RE PLAYING AT THEY'RE
PLAYING A KICKBALL GAME STAFF
VERSUS TEAM. SO MAYBE THAT
GIVES YOU AN IDEA, YOU KNOW
SOMETHING ELSE ARE THEY GOING
OUTSIDE OF THE ABLE TO GO
OUT THERE? PROBABLY GOING TO
WE GET LIKE A HALF HOUR.
OUTSIDE SO WE WERE THROWING
AROUND A FOOTBALL COUPLE DAYS
AGO. THAT WAS THE ONE THING
WE HAD A FOOTBALL IN THE
BASEBALL FIELD. THE GUYS WERE
THROWING IT AT A SOCCER BALL,
BUT I LIKE TO KICK BALL IDEA.
YEAH, THAT'S A GREAT AT
WIFFLE BALL TO I AM LIKE I'M
A PHENOMENAL WIFFLE BALL
PLAYER. SO YEAH, I GREW UP IN
CHICAGO YOU PLAY 16-INCH
SOFTBALL CHICAGO AND WIFFLE
BALL. OKAY, GREAT ONES
CHICAGO GUY PORTER MOSER. HEY
COACH. GOOD LUCK MAN. WE'RE
ALL ROOTING FOR YOU. IT'S
BEEN A PLEASURE TALKING TO
YOU. I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND
ENJOY EVERY MINUTE OF IT. I
KNOW YOU ARE. THANKS GUYS.
WE'LL SEE YOU.